Hi!
Good morning John.
It's Hank.
It's Friday.
It's Friday...
October, uh, hmm...
Gotta get out my pocket computer.
The 16th.
So we got to hangout, you and me, in Minneapolis
at NerdCon.
There's a very brief interaction between us
at the end of the most recent episode of Dear
Hank and John.
If you didn't know, we have a podcast, it's
called Dear Hank and John.
We answer your questions and give you dubious
advice and bring you all the week's news from
both Mars and AFC Wimbledon.
I feel like I'm too tall.
I feel like I set the camera up too low.
There we go.
Hey, now I'm all the way down here.
Alright.
My chair's feel low though, I feel silly now.
I got my knees all right on up on my chest.
So NerdCon went really great.
I've been literally sitting here editing NerdCon
stuff.
We're throwing some of it up on the YouTube
channel, so that people who weren't there
can see it.
And people who were can experience it again,
which I'm getting to do as I edit it: it's
really enjoyable!
I mean I do like to edit video, turns out.
It's a nice thing, after eight years of doing
something, to realize I quite like this.
I knew that I liked making videos, like, like
writing them, and getting them up on the internet,
and, like, looking at people looking at my
thing.
But I've actually realized that I like the
editing part, the sitting and the clicking
by myself.
I like the other parts.
The loud parts with the interaction and the
people and everybody watching.
But I also like the quiet, like, quiet times,
just me and my computer whose name is Greg.
Greg the Computer.
Hi Greg, how ya doing?
Oh, I know.
Always the same!
Just making that small noise of you cooling
yourself off.
Greg's a hot, he's a hottie.
I came away from NerdCon thinking a lot of
different things with a lot of different,
like, I, these are video ideas!
And as you can tell right now by the fact
that that we're quite a ways in, we haven’t
really talked about anything!
I don’t know which one to pick!
So instead I'm just "Guh!", doing one of those
videos where I scream at you and nothing happens.
Ah!
Okay, a thing: talking to Paolo Bacigalupi,
one of my favorite authors.
What do I got up here that's his?
Here’s one!
This one, Ship Breaker.
I think it won a thing, it won staff pick.
I don't think it may have won a, won a Printz,
er, a Printz honoree, I'm not sure.
Does it really matter if it was a staff pick
though at Shakespeare and Company in Missoula,
Montana which you should go to if you ever
have a chance because local bookstores, part
of the fabric that holds a community together.
Think about that next time you're on Amazon
or I'm on Amazon buying cat litter.
What was the most recent thing I bought on
Amazon?
I'm curious to find out.
The most recent thing...
(Laughs) I got a secret for you, it doesn't
smell great 'cause it was in the dirty laundry
but here it is.
It's my "no its becky" shirt, one of my very
favorite internet things that's happened on
the internet, no it becky.
Right up there with anus georg, I love anus
georg so much.
That's better, back to my normal sort of low-level
stink.
Anyway, I was talking to Paolo Bacigalupi
and we had this great conversation about how
the formats that are available to us tend
to actually influence the stories that get
told.
Like for ages the only video formats we had
were the thirty minute episode, the sixty
minute episode, and the movie length thing.
But because YouTube happened, suddenly there
was this new format that was available to
people and this format wasn't influenced by
when advertising was gonna show up or just
by the weirdness of dividing a day into 24
pieces and saying, like, "Each one of these,
that's going to be the length of a TV episode".
And it was influenced just by what's the best
possible format for telling a quick story
or making a quick thing.
And so suddenly in 2007 you have the Vlogbrothers
being, like, "We can never make a video more
than four minutes long.
We're gonna impose that artificial restriction
on ourselves" just like we did when we decided
as a culture that days were gonna have 24
hunks.
It's all arbitrary and it's weird and it's
great that we have stuck with that and, like,
this is the format.
And now that I have to say, despite the fact
that I only just got to the point, I have
to end this video because as I said, we imposed
an arbitrary distinction upon ourselves and
we must enforce it.
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.